I would imagine that there are countless
amounts of cheese out in the world
thousands if not tens of thousands so as
a cheese monger it's really hard to
answer that question of what is your
favorite cheese
hi I am Leah and I am a cheese monger I
own milk farm which is an artisan cheese
shop in Los Angeles California a cheese
monger is a person who dedicates their
life in their career to selling cheese
to the public we know everything about
cheese we can tell you all the stories
about who the cheese makers are how the
cheeses are made our job is to educate
the basic clientele on what cheese is
and how to enjoy it properly to become a
cheese monger you just really really
have to love cheese and once you get in
it's all about learning and eating a lot
along the way I feel like everybody
needs to try to go to a cheese shop it's
such a different experience because you
have a cheese monger working one-on-one
with you with all of your needs and all
of your specifications it's very
intimidating for some people but that's
the whole point of our job is to be
there to guide you through the case if
you were to come in and just say
something as simple as I love really
creamy soft spreadable cheese's that
opens a conversation for us to be able
to talk about easily 3040 cheese's right
then and there and maybe you would only
know maybe one in the case we do
recommend looking around and seeing what
we have and kind of assessing the case
but what I don't recommend is to look in
the case to look for cheese's that you
already know what is better it would be
for you to open the lines of
communication with a cheese monger and
just say hey I really enjoy this type of
cheese what do you have that similar a
cheese monger can walk you through a
dozen other cheeses and open your
dictionary and encyclopedia
I'm cheese knowledge for yourself so
what she's is should you get at the
grocery store versus our place and vice
versa you know if you just wanted like a
standard run-of-the-mill cheddar you're
just snacking with it or maybe cooking
with something like that I would say
grocery store cheese is perfectly fine
but as far as cheeses that are very
specialty like from small producers
farms to producers or pieces that are
highly seasonal those would be cheeses
that you would have to reach out to a
cheese monger for and we were able to
get because we're a specialty store if
you're buying cheese from a cheese
monger in a cheese counter most of
times it's cut to order meaning we have
the full wheel we ask you how much do
you want you won this amount and we cut
exactly what you want wrap it up and you
take it home it's always recommended
that you only get what you're going to
enjoy from today up until max about two
weeks if you buy a small quantity of
cheese it gives you the opportunity to
try a particular type of cheese lots of
different stages wheel to wheel to wheel
because they'll all be slightly
different we do a lot of pairings at
milk farm it's kind of what we really
really love to do and I think the rule
of thumb is choose what you really love
and then start from there I like to say
that when you are finding a pairing both
items need to be enhanced one can't
overtake the other a good pairing should
be able to transport you to make a good
cheese board we are mixing and matching
the whole point is actually to get a
huge range of cheeses pay particular
attention to different types of milk cow
goat sheep Buffalo or blends and then we
focus on texture soft medium and hard
and then on top of that we focus on
color whether it be from the wax of the
Rhine to the actual pieces of the cheese
and then all of those things together we
end up cutting it into different shapes
so that you don't have a super bowl tray
of cube cheese's
I really think an underrated cheese is
string cheese string cheese is super
accessible to everyone it's inexpensive
it has calcium it's portable it has its
own little wrapper like a banana and
kids love it too because it's so mild if
I'm talking about an underrated cheese
that we have at the shop
parmigiano-reggiano is my cheese that is
an underrated cheese because a lot of
people have the misconception that
parmigiano-reggiano is just parmesan
which is a lot of times it's a greenish
icky stuff or the little tiny free
packets that they give you with a to-go
order pizza but the reality is and so
the cheese that's been made for
centuries and there's a lot more uses to
it than just grading on top of pasta
that is my go-to cheese for using the
rinds for soups and stocks or just
sprinkling on top of different foods or
if I'm just having a glass of red wine I
just want to eat a chunk of cheese
that's kind of my go-to cheese processed
cheese is it really cheese processed
cheese to me is not really cheese
because if you think about how cheese is
made you really only need about three
ingredients
milk an enzyme or an acid which many
times is rennet and salt and in
processed cheese there are about 15
ingredients which include gelling agents
and food coloring and preservatives so I
wouldn't consider processed cheese
cheese I've most favorite common
misconception is that if you have a
lactose intolerance you can't enjoy
cheese it is actually false you can
enjoy faeces as long as they are aged
for a prolonged period of time some of
the aged cheese's that you can have that
are really well known that if you have
lactose intolerance you can still eat
would probably be something like man
Chico Gris err parmigiano-reggiano and
really aged Cheddar's as a cheese monger
I don't like to say that I have a
favorite cheese contrary to what I just
said I do have three cheeses that I
always have at home a string cheese as
we had discussed cheddar because I quite
often keep it up and eat it with a
plethora of different food items and
parmigiano-reggiano whatever type of
cheese is delicious to you and brings
you happiness is what you should be
eating ultimately different cheeses mean
different things to different people
maybe you have an idea of what your
favorite cheese is but it's our job to
introduce you to the world of cheese
that maybe we can turn you on to
something new
[Music]